tout a commencé il y a des mois je
venais de sauver un colonel qui s'était
fait capturer par le gang al mouacha je
pensais que c'était fini j'avais
raccrocher
mais ça ne faisait que
commencer 1 2 2 3 4
allô quoi où ça quand
ça c'est mer de
Dieu c'était qui non un faux numéro
non je m'en souviens pas
je
l'ai bon ok pourquo vous faites çaêes
pas obligé vous pas menacé il accent r
c'est flippant quand même s'il y a
vraiment un genre de jeu qu'on n pas du
tout abordé dans les JDG c'est vraiment
les FPS le premier d'ailleurs enfin pas
vraiment le premier mais en tout cas le
plus populaire c'est évidemment
Wolfenstein 3D sorti en 92 suivi du
célébrim doom en 93 d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'on a très longtemps parlé de
doomel d'ailleurs les jeux les plus
populaires encore aujourd'hui sont des
FPS alors on trouve évidemment des FPS
sur PC et sur console mais aujourd'hui
moi je vais vous parler de deux FPS sur
PC alors pourquoi sur PC et pas sur
console et bien parce qu'en ce qui
concerne les FPS moi personnellement je
suis un PCiste convaincu et que si vous
continuez à jouer à des FPS sur console
je ferai un truc dangereux du
genre je vais prendre cette bouteille
d'eau et la jeter dans la poubelle non
recyclable Elite for the Navy Seals je
suis sûr qu'il y a un générateur de nom
aléatoire pour les FPS de merde comme ça
donc un jeu sorti en 2003 4 ans après
Counter Strike pour vous resituer donc
on commence le jeu sur un écran titre et
sur une ambiance sonore qui vous met
totalement dans une ambiance de
guerre voilà il y a absolument rien du
tout d'ailleurs que ce soit au niveau du
jeu ou du son en fait je trouve ce jeu
assez artistique finalement parce que
c'est quasiment minimaliste les ennemis
ne crient pas même en mourant le jeu n'a
absolument aucune musique aucune mais
c'est même pas un bruit de vent c'est
juste rien il y a juste un vague son de
d'autoroute entendu de loin je sais pas
trop pourquoi les textures sont moches
les mecs ne savent pas faire un dégradé
de lumière les ennemis s'enfoncent dans
le sol en mourant se coincent dans les
murs le soleil ressemble à un dessin par
ma petite sœur et ma petite sœur est
morte je l'ai tué parce que ses dessins
étaient moches les décors sont
totalement vided les mecs gardent un
immense complexe de grotte complètement
gigantesque avec dedans de lit de camp
et trois tonneau tu repasseras sur
l'intérêt de défendre ce machin ah oui
et on est suréquipé évidemment
regarde-moi ça là j'ai des lunettes de
vision nocturne voyez attendez là je
l'ai mis là ah vous voyez la différence
hop hop hop hein voyez lunette de vision
nocturne voilà c'est
c'est un [ __ ] de filtre Instagram en
fait sérieux quoi et les ennemis dans ce
jeu non mais sérieusement quoi moi je
suis que le chauffeur j'ai rien à [ __ ]
et là la meuf elle arrive et puis elle
lui fait chier mon histoire ou quoi
Disle et puis là le fant est arrivé et
puis je l'aimis pas de toute façon oui
non
plus mais sérieux mais je pas jouer à ça
quoi bonjour vous êtes bien sur le
répondeur téléphonique de la
é tous nos conseillers sont actuellement
en communication veuillez rappeler
ultérieurement donc c'est parti pour
antiterror force un jeu très drôle merci
Shaka sorti en 2005 édité par Davilex et
là vous vous dites mais c'est pas un jeu
rétro attendez de voir les graphismes ce
jeu il aurait pu sortir sur Playstation
1 d'ailleurs la boîte qu'il a édité Dav
Dex est connu pour avoir fait des œuvres
d'art comme Paris merc Racing ou USA
Racing qui sont des simulations de
courses de la qualité n'est plus
approuvée bon voyons donc le jeu
commence par le tutorial donc je vais
aller régler mes touches dans les
options déjà wou classe le nom des menus
qui se chevoche ok donc position
accroupie oui ou non euh ben oui je
suppose euh attends je peux régler la
position à coupie mais je peux pas
régler mes touches euh sérieux attends
si ok j'ai rien dit pardon le menu pour
régler ses touches c'était dans carte de
contrôle bah oui et oui carte de
contrôle c'est vrai maintenant que tu le
dis c'est logique hein retournement
vertical vision
quo il il pouvait pas engager un
français tout simplement pour traduire
ça enfin je veux dire le jeu a été fait
par une boîte au Pays-Bas c'est pas
comme si c'était l'autre bout du monde h
n'empêche tu le sens venir le jeu pourri
là un peu hein alors que pourtant on a
même pas vu encore une seule image de
jeu tu sens déjà que le jeu est en train
de te préparer à la suite bon donc ok
alors les options c'est fait donc
maintenant le jeu donc réellement avant
de pouvoir commencer à jouer je vais
devoir passer par une série de tutoria
dont le premier
objectif réussissez le le cours de
recyclage alors mon petit débris de
prépus devient po de chamb des Alpes
combien de fois devrais-je te dire que
la poyène et le polyurétine ne se jette
pas dans la poubelle jaune ta mère doit
Têtre morte de honte espèce de B tessur
de Black
carabar bon allez donc c'est parti pour
le tuto on a tout d'abord droit à une
superbe voix of dit de Julien qui nous
demande débarrasse ton avion de la
rouille qu'il a envahi et effectue le
test d'entraînement débarrasser l'avion
de la rouille quoi bon on va dire que
c'est métaphorique que l'avion c'est
nous et que la roue c'est vous savez
quoi j'emmerde les métaphores en
fait ou là merde mes bras sont partis
tout seul j'étais pas censé bouger
pendant la cinématique désolé c'est ma
faute bon donc la première partie du
tutoriel consiste à trouver qu'en fait
il faut activer la radio au centre pour
lancer le tuto parce que sinon tu peux
tout faire mais ça ser rien tu ne le
finiras pas ensuite on a différentes
parties comme l'entraînement à la
grenade l'entraînement au parcours
d'obstacle ou l'entraînement à se cacher
j'aime bien celui-là puisqu'il faut se
cacher d'un sniper ennemi B c'est cool
c'est un entraînement mais tu peux te
faire tuer normal quoi oh ça va bien tu
fais quoi oh non rien je lu vais un café
et cet après je de buté mais ce qui est
particulièrement génialissime dans ce
jeu c'est que ce jeu n'a absolument
aucune notion de la musique ce mec là
que vous voyez est atteint de la maladie
de la musique d'ambiance quand quand tu
lui tires dessus en fait ça va
déclencher une musique complètement
aléatoirement une musique d'ambiance qui
ne s'emboî absolument pas du tout dans
tout le reste du jeu je ve dire les
musiques sont bien j'ai rien à reprocher
aux musiques c'est juste que tu imagines
tout sauf le ghygiène dessus genre je
veux dire tout le jeu tu as cette espèce
de petite musique là qu'on entend en
musique tranquille qui pourrait presque
s'insérer dans un jeu de gestion genre
Sim
City et dès que tu tires sur quelqu'un
moi en tant que jeune je suis content
d'être client à la Maïf parce que depuis
que je suis client à la Maïf je paye mes
assurances 15 % moins cher oui parce que
chez nous à la Maïf nous offrons 15 % de
réduction à nos jeunes assurés parce que
chez nous on croit en la
jeunesse enfin bref donc après ça on a
un long passage de tuto complètement
ridicule tu dois tirer sur des cibles
qui parfois ne s'activent que quand tu
sors de la pièce garde ça la cible est
dans le sol c'est très intelligent he
parce que c'est vrai que c'est hyper
fréquent quand tu rentres dans une pièce
que tu vérifies qu' il y a personne
dedans qu'un ennemi sorte du sol dans
ton dos hein grâce à l'entraînement du G
vous pourrez vous battre contre toutes
sortes d'ennemis qui sortent du sol tel
des vers de terre des des tops et cetera
ouais j'ai
réussi Misson
accomplie et donc là on arrive enfin à
la première mission avec une prise
d'otage dans les bureaux du Premier
ministre à Londres en Angleterre au
Royaume-Uni pas en France et qui c'est
qu'on appelle le G
donc tout d'abord évidemment on a le
briefing évidemment toujours présenté
par le journaliste de France 3 Bourgogne
le personnel du 10 Downing Street a été
prise en otage et ils sont retenus par
un groupe d'insurgés sous la menace d'un
revolver [ __ ] cette voix de recette de
cuisine fait un effort
merde le Premier ministre a été enlevé
par une bande de terroristes qui veulent
faire sauter la planète le destin du
monde repose entre tes épaules attends
non je sais trop à quoi ça fait pens en
fait sa dans dans les grandes surfaces
les petits écrans dans les rayons
bricolag c'est la même voix en fait avec
déc plus le papier peint ne fait pas
un attention on a des coéquipiers
maintenant ça devient sérieux dommage
que vos coéquipiers soi aussi efficace
qu'e de malade bon alors moi je garde
cette fenêtre il y a personne qui
rentrera par cette fenêtre c'est bon on
a sécurisé l'arrière des canapés tout va
bien là onit
coinc coinc
on est coincé merde je veux pas crever
ici j'ai une femme et des gosses oh
mince il y un
terroriste bon ben les terroristes sont
pas vraiment Miotti je vous
rassure coucou je suis un terroriste un
gros gros je suis méchant
ok s'il y a quelqu'un qui passe par le
mur je le tue direct allez mon petit
Raoul continue à tirer on va la voir ce
mur ce jeu est génial en fait parce que
quand tu joues au moins tu te fais pas
chier quand tu joues à ce jeu tu te sens
pousser une âme de betta tester et tu
commences à chercher tous les bugs qui
sont un peu partout dans le jeu le
principal problème des terroristes c'est
qu'ils sont cloué au solin même s'ils
ont 1,50 à faire pour venir vous tuer
ils ne les feront pas ah merde il est de
l'autre côté de la table je peux pas y
aller oh mon dieu il est accroupi
comment fait-il ça je ne peux plus le
toucher au passage noter la superbe
animation des otages qui restent
parfaitement immobiles pendant les
fusillades je suis un otage et je vais
bien bref mission 2 don attends est-ce
que j'ai vu un bras là d'accord il y a
une image subliminale de bras entre la
mission 1 et la mission 2 ok bon enfin
bref on s'en fout allez mission 2
mission 2 Il faut sauver le président
Jacques Chirac dans l'Élysée oui il y a
Jacques Chirac en 3D dans ce
jeu bon alors effectivement je suis
d'accord ça ressemble davantage à un
hôtel campagille qu'à l'idée que je me
faisais de l'Élysée moi aussi je pensais
que ça serait un poil plus chic hein je
vous avoue mais au moins ce niveau donne
la preuve que les gens chez davidex sont
vraiment cliniquement cons he et en
danger ta mission est de t'infiltrer
dans le bâtiment localiser le président
et l'escorter jusqu'à ce qu'il soit en
sécurité tu dois tenter de ne pas te
faire repérer on est d'accord he je dois
tenter de ne pas me faire repérer c'est
donc de l'infiltration donc attention
début de
mission on nous
attaque bande de [ __ ] de rectum vous
dites de pas se faire repérer et vous
faites commencer la mission à côté pile
à côté d'un ennemi sérieusement c'est
complètement stupide je veux dire autant
te mettre directement un ta de 5 minutes
d'entrée si c'est pour faire
genre et voilà [ __ ] ils ont tué les
otages cette musique de Game
Over je crois que j'ai jamais entendu
quelque chose de ma vie d'autant
évite de te faire repérer GO
GO le GN nous avons changé non mais
sérieusement comment tu les trouves toi
plutôt sympa franchement ça marche pas
ou quoi bon bref donc pour revenir au
jeu cette mission est sincèrement
quasiment impossible ennemi te voit si
tu le tues pas quasiment immédiatement
il crie tuer les otages et la mission
s'arrête et cette merde a l'air
complètement aléatoire en plus des fois
tu te balades dans le couloir il y a
personne tu as pas été repéré il y a
rien et tu entends
subitement sans aucune raison et
d'autres fois le mec passe en face de
toi il te voit je suis en face de lui et
il réagit pas allez vas-y tu l' tes
otages la con de toi et puis merde il y
a 40 terroristes je dois sauver le
président de la République alors fuck
pourquoi je suis tout seul [ __ ] on
nous attaque bon les mecs le président
de la République qui a été enlevé par
une quarantaine de terroristes qui
occupe l'Élysée alors on va envoyer
euh toi et après vas-y je parlerai même
pas de tous les trucs évidents les
objectifs sont pas clairs les armes font
un bruit dégueulasse l'animation est
pourrie il y a pas de carte de niveau
pour te répérer tout ce que te dis la
voix off c'est prends les escaliers de
l'autre côté du bâtiment évite de te
faire repérer sérieux de 1 je suis déjà
repéré et de deux de l'autre côté du
bâtiment par par rapport à quoi [ __ ]
c'est quoi cette musique de croquette
pour chien là j'ai l'impression d'êre
dans une pub de Royal Canin merde je
suis dans ce jeu pour les fou moi tout
ce que je veux voir c'est shirac en 3D
où es-tuir président est dans la salle
avant est dans la salle avant ça ve rien
dire mais je vais y arriver
ouais je l'ai il est là maintenant il
faut que je l'amène sur le toit de
l'Élysée c'est là où il y a plein de
piscine des transat et des palmiers faut
pas que je crêve faut pas que je crêve
ah
you are very good
Mr now it is time meet me at the Hel
attendez 8 mois mais pourquoi faire
pourquoi pas maintenant je suis
disponible mentends là all
all attends oui attends je vais monter
les escaliers attends
voilà pourquoi vous m'avez fait venir
iciuse
it is
time to dan